[Music]
with freedom comes responsibility
your decision to be unvaccinated impacts
someone else
unvaccinated people spread the virus
president biden invoking freedom as he
pushes vaccine initiatives and even
offering americans up to a hundred
dollars
to get the shot so weird uh this is mass
mandate's return
for many in this country including for
the fully vaccinated figure that out
here was reaction the host of the ben
shapiro show and author of the brand new
book the author
authoritarian moment ben shapiro joins
us hey ben good morning to you
hey good morning you know the white
house has got a messaging problem there
are a hundred million
90 million unvaccinated americans
yesterday
the president made the case everybody
who can
needs to get vaccinated and until then
people need to wear a mask even though
they've had vaccinations even though he
said
get the shot and then you don't have to
wear it so they've got a messaging
problem
which they invented themselves
that's exactly right the public health
experts here have completely failed when
it comes to messaging this thing
here is the reality if you have had the
vaccine you're extremely safe from covet
at this point there have been 161
million people in the united states who
have been double vaxxed at this point
there are 6 000 people who have had
breakthrough infections resulting in
hospitalizations
and about 1700 people who have died
after that which means that your chances
of even being hospitalized with covid
after getting the vaccine are somewhere
around 1 in 27
000 in the united states and now they
are saying that the vaccinated are
supposed to mask up to prevent the
unvaccinated
from getting the disease well there's
only one problem with that that actually
encourages the unvaccinated to remain
unvaccinated because everybody else is
now working
to prevent them from getting the
infection everybody's going to get in
fact
look there are only two paths here one
is you get vaccinated you get immune
that way the other is you get covered
and you get immune that way
everybody now gets to choose that's
called being an adult yeah
yeah i think that's key and plus uh 74
of the people that do have breakthroughs
are over 65.
so that further lessens the chances uh
depending on
your age bracket in life and most
seniors have gotten vaccinated already
yesterday's uh uh stage show
was uh really anxiety written because
now we're
re-empowering the mayors and governors
who tortured us last year
especially the state you just left in
california
it's madness i mean washington dc just
announced these new mass
mandates washington dc has a running
average of zero
zero coveted deaths every day right los
angeles county which is a county
of like 10 million people los angeles
county has single digit coveted deaths
every day looking at the case rate
doesn't make a difference looking at the
death rate makes the difference
this is the whole re this is the reason
people are supposed to get vaccinated is
because we have now disconnected
the case rate from the death rate right
if we're only going to just focus in on
the case rate and not on the death rate
who's going to get vaccinated
that's such a great point ben i want to
get to your book because um i think we
are in an authoritarian moment i think
it's a
really really great title um here's an
excerpt from it a small number of
leftists college educated coastal
and uncompromising have not just taken
over the democrat party
but our corporations our universities
our scientific establishment
our cultural institutions and they have
used their newfound power
to silence their opposition ben movement
conservatives like you have been talking
about the takeover
by the left of the culture of hollywood
of education
i've been really surprised at how
thoroughly they've infiltrated
government um you know the national
security now the military
talk to me about this authoritarian
movement but also about what's the
solution to this
well i think that to understand the
solution we have to understand that the
way that these institutions were taken
over is you need a very hard core of
about 20 percent
of a group 20 any group inside an
institution that is uncompromising
and insists on getting its way and you
need a bunch of people in the middle who
are just apathetic or
who are shy and and that's what's
happened in all of these institutions
well the good news is
that you can do it in reverse if 20 of a
corporation 20
of the employees get together and they
say we are not doing x
in opposition to the left then they can
swing that middle back the other way and
you can return neutrality to some of
these institutions but that requires
some actual organization
it requires almost a political
unionization movement by conservatives
or moderates
in a variety of areas of american life
if that doesn't happen the left's going
to continue its march through the
institutions
well check out the book it is now
available everywhere i'm sure it's going
to be a big
number one new york times bestseller
it's called the authoritarian movement
ben shapiro thank you very much for
joining us live from
down in florida thanks so much thank you
ben